we told you at the top you'd be able to
assess for yourself whether West is
crazy as virtually every single media
Outlet on planet Earth claims every day
all year long is he crazy
as you try to assess that ask is what
you just heard over the past 40 minutes
any crazier than what you see on
television every day the lies the lunacy
presented you with a straight face as
reality no it's not it's not crazy at
all he's a big thinker though we asked
him about 2024 what he plans to do and
also about Elon Musk here it is
people with power try to make other
people feel like they don't have any
my power is through God
so if someone ever says anything like oh
you did a great job it's praise God
it's funny atheists love the term
narcissist
when you believe in yourself right they
say that it's narcissistic
you know I love the way
I love the dynamic of how you compare
you you show that there's still
Humanity
even with the position that God has
placed me in
why did Moses Smite The Rock why do you
get that frustrated
and
just to
to be able to be gentle to be more
gentle you know God is alive look at
this right here
look at look at how quiet it is right
now it's only God is of order the devil
is of Chaos
that is true you know we are
I I want to I want to
talk about
my uh potential run for 2024
and Trump's
uh potential run for 2024 and the
Beloved DeSantis potential run for 2024
and mayor Suarez potential run for 2024
and
you know they thought Trump was a joke
for older white people
they're quick
to classify a black person only by the
fact that we're black
even even Trump a person that's you know
we'd consider to be a friend of mine
uh when I went to the White House
uh I called him uh after that
to get ASAP Rocky out of jail
and one of the things he said to me is
you know Kanye you're my friend when you
came to the White House my black
approval rating went up 40 percent
and
four politicians
all black people are worth is approval
as an approval rating
the Democrats feel that they don't owe
us anything
and Republicans feel that they don't owe
us anything
blacks have never demanded something for
our vote and that's something I talked
to Ice Cube about
what are we asking for how do we change
our life if all of our organizations and
all of our colleges and even our title
was black was made by white people all
of our organ all you know all of our
jobs
and Black Wall Street
uh
Harlem after gentrification there's
never been a fully black owned Community
where we we have all the municipalities
things that uh Dr Claude Anderson talks
about
we need that it's like 90 of America
is not even developed
I'm not one of the people that go up and
say Hey I want to stop anybody from
making money the people that make money
and the powers that be I am your true
Nikolai Tesla
and I'm not even a scientist
what do you think of Elon Musk do you
know him very well
what's your take on him you said that
because I said Tesla I did yeah it's the
first thing that and that everyone's
always like oh elon's got these answers
I think he's a great
I think he's a great team player
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight